effie do you have a question for conan
at all uh yes my question is um so in
the hospital in the icu we have a lot of
conversations obviously um when things
get tough about you know where you want
your life to go and what you want from
your life and um if things
get taken away from you so in in the
event that things go south for you conan
if what do you mean um
what year i mean i can name seven
periods of my career where they went
clearly south from me i mean medically
south oh medically
so what are your dying wishes and when
do we pull the plug
well first of all let me write this down
by the way detailed speaking of earlier
of my wife my wife wants to pull the
blog constantly
she's like let's insert a plug and then
pull it
uh i'm fine uh that's a really wow
that's a powerful question and i do
think gurley's gonna probably go and
find this episode when the time comes
that's right which if corey gets his
wish will be very soon uh my last wishes
are i wish to be immortalized with a
giant statue oh i thought you're going
to say you wish to be immortal
no no
trust me i've looked into it it's too
late for that um i would like a big
over-the-top funeral i would like a
large statue to be unveiled of me on
horseback even though in life i didn't
ride horses
uh i want i to be treated um with full
military honors even though i
did not serve in the military
every branch oh my god i want jets going
overhead i want uh coast guard as well
coast guard i want full coast guard
salute it's got to be done near the
water so that there can be guns firing
from and i you know some people are very
humble and they just want oh i just want
a simple
simple casket or i i uh
and i'm going completely the other way
okay i want honors that i'm not entitled
to in life
i want to get them in death okay uh and
i want there to be a national day of
mourning and i want my event i also want
my casket to tour the country
lincoln's toured the country for several
weeks
after he died after he was shot it it
took this train trip all around the
country and people could go and see
lincoln um i want mine to travel
to tour for like like aerosmith i wanted
to be two and a half years a two and a
half year tour
and i wanted to go to tokyo
uh i want to go through mostly european
cities international oh international
yeah i want it to be i want to go
everywhere
uh
and um i just want there to be a huge
fuss would you mind if this tour is just
connected to an aerosmith tour that's
fine
that would be fantastic basket you know
in life
you know conan gave his all and now
okay
[Music]
and then they bring my k my body out and
they
like
yeah yeah exactly put some stephen tyler
scarves around me and then using some of
the um defibrillator technology
get me moving around the stage you know
just shoot me up through of electricity
i love that i love that so those are my
last wishes okay and um pull the plug
uh man i just think wait till you hear
from my tour manager when it's time to
go i want to go i want to make sure we
sell out completely so once we've sold
out the tour even if i'm starting to
recover make sure i'm killed
let's put a pillow over my head and get
me out but we're talking this is going
to be a very expensive
international funeral slash aerosmith
tour and um
he's really drawing up a contract and
signing it
okay yeah i worry now he's official now
you know adam is already looking into
ticket sales over there
yeah i'm worried now this is going to
get me killed the tour starts on monday
yeah
[Laughter]
we just got such a good rate you just
got a sign here and all right i'm going
to assign this down i'm going to sign
this right here and then you need to
witness this okay
this is my directive this is my
signature
can you see this pretty well effie this
is the whole directive oh yeah wow okay
and um
we need you to verbally agree that you
and then i'll put your name down okay
okay do you verbally agree that this
meets with your approval i do yeah we'll
make a copy of it put in the chart